For a long time, the Name Node was a single point
of failure in Hadoop. If it died, the entire cluster was
inaccessible. If the meta data on the Name Node was lost
completely, the entire cluster's data was lost. Sure, you've still got
all the blocks on the data nodes but you've no way
of knowing which block belongs to which file whithout the meta
data. So, to avoid the problem, people would configure the Name
Node to store meta data, not only on it's own hard drive
but also somewhere on a network file system. NFS
is a method of mounting a remote disk. That way,
even if the Name Node bursts into flames, there
would be a copy of the metadata elsewhere on the
network. These days, there's an even better alternative. The
Name Node is not a single point of failure in
most production clusters, because they've configured two Name Nodes.
The active Name Node works as before, but the standby
can be configured to take over if the active one
fails. That way the cluster will keep running if any of
the nodes, even one of the Name Nodes, fails. Ian's
now going to show us a demonstration of how to use HDFS.